i think and maybe this is a comedic
thing for me
i people often times go like jokes are
jokes are wrong or jokes are right or
blah blah blah or jokes or speak about
the truth jokes aren't truthful right we
lie all the time like how often is the
misdirect something that completely
didn't happen
right like the whole point of the joke
is the lie i think seinfeld actually
said that really well
but the feeling within the joke is true
and the problem is a lot of us don't
want to
acknowledge the feelings that we have
and i think one of the reasons why
you've had well that's what chapter
three and beyond order is about right
don't hide things in the fog and it's
definitely the case that what comedians
do
often is point to something and say look
we have that hidden in the fog
and here's what it is and everyone
laughs it's like yeah that's really what
it is
yeah so yeah that happens a lot
so and you use fiction it's not so much
lie it's fiction
right in fiction is fiction is more than
true in some sense because
it's like the it's like the average of
truth look a great novel is more
realistic than life
itself and because who the hell wants to
read a novel about how many times you
blinked after you woke up this morning
right if you wrote down every detail
it's just not relevant or interesting
you want to sift through your life and
pull out what's what's importantly true
yeah and and fiction pulls out what's
importantly true about
lots of people's lives and amalgamates
it together into one story yes
so it's hyper true it's it's what's more
than true
and that's why it's so useful and when
you use fiction
on stage when you use fiction and
performance you're doing the same thing
you're
you're drawing on this ability so for
example when a little kid
plays dad when he's playing house
you say well he's imitating his father
but that's not right because if you
watch the child
he doesn't do exactly what he saw his
father do that day
what he doesn't say is he watches his
father in many many situations and he
gets the gist
and then he acts out the gist just like
someone who does an imitation
all the time they do limitations yeah
yeah and it's not like they
do exactly what they saw the person
doing
they watch them across lots of
situations and they act or speak
like they would in that situation and so
it's true
but it isn't an accurate representation
of something that actually happened
so it's a very funny form of truth that
doesn't make it trivial
it it's a it's more true and and i think
oftentimes when you're dealing with
things that uh these feelings that are
more true right let's just talk about
these like these these feelings itself
a lot of times now especially with like
the you know
the political landscape it is terrifying
for the average person
right to express a feeling that might be
high stakes
and i think this is one of the reasons
why
you became so uh addictive for lack of a
better word and there are other people
that are in your same vein
where it's like you created these very
safe structures to express a
feeling that we all had right the
average person might come out and they
might say i don't
know an example but uh i don't think the
sky is blue
right you would have a nuanced specific
way of saying
that the sky is blue
i'm probably being confusing here but
you would have a non-specific way of
saying it
where they wouldn't have to feel like if
they went to work the next day everybody
would judge them
i don't think a lot of people have these
feelings the average person i'm not
talking about the extremists but the
average person has a feeling and it
doesn't make them a bad person
but today depending on what you say you
could be looked that way
and the nuances will be almost certainly
100 percent and so the nuanced thinkers
that's why it's so deadly that so many
comedians are now uncomfortable to
perform
yeah yeah comedians are canaries in the
coal mine man when
when comedians start censoring
themselves you know something's gone
wrong
they're the first they're the first line
i think they're out there in front of
the artists
that's my sense of popular culture the
first people to go are the comedians
because they they're the ones that take
well they take risk with speech that's
part of it and it's
it's there has to be a spontaneity and a
daring so they're always testing the
limits of what's acceptable in speech
and they're almost always doing it in a
way that points to uncomfortable truths
in one form or another things that
people won't admit things that we keep
hidden in the dark
the foibles of our leaders you know
anything that that's there but makes
people too uncomfortable to talk about
that's exactly what a comedian hones in
on
institutions right we make fun of the
institutions
and i think when comedy is best is is
when those
institutions are a little bit oppressive
i think the best comics come from those
times like
all these comics get upset about like
what's happening right now i'm like you
should be
salivating this is our time
this is when we push back this is where
it's fun baby
what would you do without some
oppression yes
you need it we need depression so we
don't become sociopaths we need
oppression so we could be great
comedians like
that when when you could say whatever
you want comedy gets
weird you you know those times where
like comedy's all like quirky like i'm
gonna have a [ __ ] clown nose and i'm
gonna be like super absurdist like it
just means nothing
the second you tell us we can't say
something you get the carlins
you get the priors you get the chris
rocks you get the chappelles
you know it to me i think this you
should be so excited if you're a
[Applause]
comedian
you